[Musique]
on
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 culture
aujourd'hui nous sommes dans les rues de
château pour découvrir les fresques
street art de la ville voici le sommaire
six façades si tu aimes et six artistes
différents le street art s'est invitée
dans les rues de château depuis le mois
de juin de fraises que viennent d'être
sélectionnés pour les golden fréthun
2021 focus sur les oeuvres il est
directeur d'une agence de construction
métallique à buchelay mais aussi
musicien à ses heures perdues jobs
présente son premier album intitulé
prologue rencontre et enfin jusqu'au 19
mars le festival odyssée en yvelines
revient dans les lieux culturels
libinois avec six créations théâtrales
nous avons assisté à l'une d'entre elles
je me trouve devant la résidence les
marolles à chatou ici vous pouvez voir
derrière moi la fresque de l'artiste
vignes graffitis cette oeuvre est
sélectionné pour les golden street art
2021 michel grelier bonjour vous êtes
l'adjointe au maire à la culture
chatou est ce que vous pouvez me
présenter tout d'abord cette fresque
alors cette phrase que ces diversités
vini graffiti donc qui est une artiste
française to z qui est jeune qui de 1989
dont vraiment et qui a une audience on
va dire internationale puisque ces
fresques sont dans le monde entier et
voilà avec une thématique est bien
particulière c'est ce visage que de la
jeune fille quiconque est récurrent sur
toutes ses oeuvres donc voilà et on le
voit aussi ses cheveux il perd ses
cheveux alors la thématique achats tout
parce que tous les artistes avaient une
thématique
survie ni graffiti c'est la diversité et
donc dans ses cheveux si vous voyez il a
écouté différence biodiversité
religion enfin tout ce qui concerne la
diversité et qu'elle exprime au travers
de son art alors cette fresque comme je
le disais a été présélectionné pour les
golden street art 2021 ce que vous ayez
le m'expliquer ce qu'est ce que
l'instructeur 2021 set ça fait huit ans
que ça existe en fait c'est la plus
grande banque de données de photos de
street art français et je crois à peu
près 16 milles et tous les orbes elle
décerne à trophées à la meilleure oeuvre
de street art alors on a la chance à
chaque d'avoir
l'immigration qui qui a été sélectionnée
est plutôt bien placé et donc vous le
disiez une autre oeuvre elle aussi
apprécié du public signent carlos
alberto elle figure à l'entrée du
collège renoir tout à fait à l'entrée du
collage benoît donc carlos alberto c'est
un mexique acquis aussi connu de manière
voyez internationale et sa thématique
c'était développement durable donc la
particularité de carlos alberto sur ses
fresques ces deux-là morphose donc son
en 3d et c'était très intéressant parce
qu'il a il a pris en fait un petit peu
les oiseaux qui assure sur chatou le
martin-pêcheur des agneaux qu'on
retrouve et le résultat est plutôt
superbe passe et ça parce que finalement
les fresques représentent un peu chatou
tout à fait c'était l'idée en fait et
chaque fresque à une thématique qui va
exprès la sensibilité de chacun nous
nous sommes partis voir ce qu'ont pensé
les principales intéressées les
habitants de chatou regarder je trouve
très bien je trouve que la ville est la
plus jolie ça fait acter j'aime bien si
ça peut embellir le paysage urbain oui
oui et celle qui est là-bas ou sinon la
petite fresque aussi web ça aussi c'est
très beau ils ont fait cet été oui le
l'oiseau juste devant juste devant le
collège c'est très beau ma préférée
c'est la jeune fille qui a dessiné
ancien artiste une petite artistes que
dessiner avec des mots dans les cheveux
elle a des cheveux crépus et des
bouclettes oui c'est bien ça me choque
pas je me laisse à quai des tags moi je
trouve ça mieux ça fait des couleurs au
moins ça change d'avoir des murs
classique sans rien et puis voilà c'est
bien alors michel legré lien on a vu la
réaction plutôt positive un des
habitants c'était une volonté de la
mairie de château de s'emparer de l'art
contemporain vous êtes associé en juin
avec lo n'diaye street art for mankind
pour la création de ces divers fresque
dans différents quartiers de la commune
pourquoi finalement et comment ça c'est
fait alors comment ça a été une rentrant
d'une rencontre fortuite entre monsieur
le maire et puis ces personnes qui
représentent le ng qui sont en fait
c'est une ong américaine mais créé par
deux français un couple de français qui
habite au
aux états unis et alors pourquoi on
était très très partisan de travailler
avec eux parce qu'en fait cette ong
défend le droit des enfants notamment
voilà le travail le droit à l'éducation
un petit peu tout ça est que ben on se
trouvait que c'était intéressant de se
greffer donc c'est pour ça qu'on est
parti avec cette ong et gens viennent en
a pris puisque les fresques sont
vraiment de toute beauté avec vraiment
des artistes de grande qualité et donc
elle va rester en principe la durée
d'une vie d'une phrase une dizaine
d'années a appris avec le temps ça se
détériore mais voilà c'est à peu près
cette durée de vie vous repartirez
pétète j'ai prévu en 2000 foot en 2023
de continuer encore sur deux ou trois
fresques sachant que là cette année il
ya 3 3 petites phrases qui vont être
présentés mais par des artistes français
sur des transformateurs électriques et
va très bien merci beaucoup mais c'est
le grenier d'avoir été austral et edward
passé de directeur d' agences de
construction métallique à musiciens qui
compose et chante c'est la vie
quotidienne de baptiste jobs il nous
présente son premier album prologue
rencontre là où il a composé une partie
mélodies il est 17h30 baptiste jobs a
fini sa journée ce directeur d' agences
de construction métallique à buchelay va
pouvoir se consacrer maintenant à sa
deuxième vie la journée le constructeur
métallique est maintenant terminée et là
je vais pouvoir m'adonner à ma passion
une passion
qui est très prenante également mais qui
est extrêmement importante pour moi
direction rolleboise au domaine de la
corniche baptiste jobs devient jobs
havrais l'artiste d'or et demi par
semaine dans cet établissement là bas un
coin piano est à sa disposition
là on arrive dans mon petit coin secret
dans l'hôtel de la corniche
où je prends un chandelier de l'hôtel
et je m'installe
au piano du bar c'est ici en fin de
compte que j'ai que j'ai écrit que j'ai
peaufiné pas mal de paroles de chansons
notamment celle ci docteur
[Musique]
cette chanson fait partie de son premier
album prologue 15 titres interprétés par
l'artiste avec l'aide de trois autres
musiciens havre et le style job c'est de
ne pas en avoir donc ça peut être
finalement quand je fais là quand je
fais de la route justement jusqu'au
havre je passe un péage d'autoroute et
là j'ai imaginé une histoire d'amour
avec une jolie guichetière au péage ça
peut être les idées qui me sont venues à
la suite du drame du bataclan en une
seule nuit là j'ai imaginé une chanson
qui s'appelle mourir de vivre il a
tourné aussi le clip de sa chanson la
mécanique des sentiments une chanson
d'amour adressée à son piano jobs mène
deux vies différentes qui ne sont
finalement pas si éloigné que ça je
pense que je suis dans la musique un peu
comme je suis dans la construction c'est
à dire très méticuleux très précis parce
que c'est la construction une charpente
métallique ça se prépare quand on arrive
sur un chantier
tout est déjà normalement bien
orchestrée pour ça se passe bien et bien
une chanson c'est pareil après un
premier concert au havre jobs
souhaiteraient se faire connaître
davantage dans les yvelines il est
également en préparation du tournage
d'un nouveau clip pour sa chanson un
aller sans retour du chanson est pour
tous
ce soir
flavia coelho l'artiste brésilienne sera
en concert à la clé des champs à plaisir
vendredi 18 février elle nous présentera
son nouvel album dna aux inspirations
groove et hip hop on écoute l'artiste
suite d'un esprit musicalement c'est un
disque bien sûr qu'elle est un peu ce
que j'appelle ma patte c'est de mélanger
du verset rythme diverses et variées
jouer avec des basses
de sonorités plus urbaines et toujours
avoir des guitares brésilienne
avoir voilà le flou la tchatche les
influences musicales du brésil et de la
caraïbe et celle que je me beaucoup
utilisé depuis longtemps ensuite au
niveau des paroles c'est un disque un
peu plus à rentrer dedans parce que je
voulais à tout prix
parler de l'actualité ce qui est en
train d'arriver dans mon pays en fait
l'arrivée des ex thème
des choses qui existent depuis toujours
en fait le racisme c'est l'égalité et un
sac alexa procès mada pichard
c'est pas du pain du lait va abattre
[Musique]
c'est à dire
et si tu danses c'est le spectacle
interactif proposé aux tout petits dès 4
ans il se produira dans divers lieux
culturels yvelinois comme les théâtres
ou encore les bibliothèques il fait
partie également des six création
théâtrale originale proposée par le
festival odyssée en imad chacun
à thé de 12 tonnes
tu as dû être montant carrément
toi tu avais de casser d'un des pierres
qui raconte une histoire la différence
la figure du petit poucet s'exprime à
travers et si tu danses un spectacle
conçu par la chorégraphe marion lévy à
destination des tout petits dès 4 ans je
les crée aussi avec l'aide de mariette
navarro qui est aux tris et on a inventé
ensemble cette histoire du petit poucet
et à chaque fois on part d'une
thématique ou d'une figure et puis on
invente notre propre histoire on avait
fait déjà des spectacles jeune public
mais la 4 5 ans c'est aussi un défi et
et là bas en tout cas il m'a ça marche
bien interactif le spectacle permet aux
enfants de participer à l'avancé du
récit en donnant des indications
scéniques
oui
c'est exactement ça
j'ai bien aimé et c'était bien quand on
a fait la gueule du pet il croyait la
ramasser des cailloux du coup ça me fait
plaisir de te aller voir un spectacle
aime bien c'était bien de rôle et quelle
troquant la danse et la représentation
se termine avec tous les enfants sur
scène et si tu danses fait partie des
six créations théâtrales du festival
odysée en yvelines organisée par le
théâtre de sartrouville 13e édition
jusqu'au 19 mars c'est la première fois
que je participe à ce festival et c'est
une commande donc du théâtre de
sartrouville c'est vrai que c'est un
spectacle tout terrain puisque en plus
le moins jeu c'est vrai que la
contrainte quand ils m'ont dit le
théâtre m'a dit on peut aller dans des
bibliothèques des socios des mains
théâtre mais pas que je me suis dit je
vais partir de l'a25 de cette contrainte
là et si tu danses ainsi que les cinq
autres créations partent en tournée dès
maintenant dans plus de 58 et culturel
lillois différents comme les théâtres et
bibliothèque ou encore les centres
sociaux
[Musique]
et c'est la fin de ce set 8 culture
merci de nous avoir suivis rendez vous
la semaine prochaine dans un autre lieu
culturel et benoît bonne soirée sur
l'exercice
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]